season in power washer if you haven't played the entire campaign it doesn't allow you to
have six persons in your lobby and I'm the only one with a finished save file and it
was too late to like ship all the like coding information to like send on on your stream
yeah and so basically she be rescued she be was like right I'll set this one out you
guys just do it and we're like no we can't do it the whole point of this is that we're
all together in this so then we're like right who's got gmod right I don't have it right
who's got raft right I don't have it right who's got this game I don't have it I was
trying my best she was like going through the list she was flicking them pages like next
page next page next game next game okay don't work literally okay sure alright we'll do
jack pox and then wait that requires us to screen record the discord I'm like we can't
have that we see outrageous things in the discord we don't even have a hr department
so we can't share so then garlic phone which I've never played before is coming in clutch
right now emmy's currently making a cup of tea mercy em is just getting a room set up
for her em because she accidentally nuked her vault of her to the collapse dream of
it was a disaster this couldn't have gone any worse so just I think that's like pretty
on character yeah if someone insert that meme and put all of her hairs on it oh aren't v
troopers cute when they're almost hmm or a little that's all I'm gonna say well you
guys can finish the sentence after that but that was I can't no no no no no no no no no
no refunds the snow very simply in hearts the harem I remember I was like okay I'm gonna
be honest when they when the harem told me they were called harem I read as harem and
I was like that makes no sense for shibu's character design I did too I was like what
I have a harem of so many people that are my little you know play things and clients
and they're my harem and that's hair which is a rabbit but it's not a rabbit hair and
rabbit are different but you know what I mean it's a good fun it's a pun exactly and they're
also called harleys and if the individuals are harleys or harleys wait hold on I thought
you said hairless they're hairless some of them aren't I can tell you that
Marcy you could do you still have that thumbnail Marcy from I got it almost almost to me Marcy
if you still have that thumbnail if you just throw up the stream is she gonna throw up
on stream no yeah it should default to that if you just change to the thumbnail and pick
our take off I'm dying I cannot right now oh my goodness gracious
yeah yeah how's the volume yeah it's my volume okay can you hear everyone else
I need them to be clean and proper volume good I see it I see it okay okay that's good
how'd I change the verdict phone on managed broadcast on OBS
yeah any gifters for my non-monetized
oh my gosh I was muted I was muted the entire time oh my god
no what is this this is a fever dream guys we're all in bed well I guess I should change
my stuff now why do we need to change we don't have to change anything as long as
I'm on stream you can change it after stream no one gives a shit okay it's called as long as
we're online right now okay okay I'm just doing it cuz we're all there's like I'm sitting here the
girls running around like everything's on fire and I'm like it'll be fine we're good we're gonna
play some magic phone we're gonna have a great time I think the world is gonna end
don't forget to like and subscribe on this stream if you're enjoying your experiences
smash that bell to get notifications of when we go live that bell to get smashed
yeah like with alcohol or something yeah I am yeah I can't help myself I love I love
she loves smashing like like she just says smashing like and that's it you know she just
loves I see love smashing here no I'm barely here are you I'm sorry for the mess yeah we're
here she's talking to her chat we have viewer have done the holistic approach where none of us
will mute so yeah yeah that's how we're all it just as a reminder all donations my
membership super chats will be addressed at the end of the stream when it's not an absolute cluster
buck of all six of us together but yes the whole premise of the power washer was I was gonna do a
gag and be like oh be allure isn't doing so well we might go buzz so everyone put a bikini on and
get clean in well window now so instead we're playing garlic phone I've never played it personally
she be suggested it and I her word is law so oh yes I am taking over the company I am the shadow
CEO okay do you guys want to start you ready yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let's do it let's
three two one let's go what a sense I know cheating the guy is so chat don't fucking
do it I swear I'll beat your ass
I don't think they'll actually know what that is so let me change it I know oh we don't have
I can't see don't she
this is so bad oh no it's happening why are you guys screaming oh my god
holy fuck the tall break the indicator not the shading I'm an artist an artist oh yeah wait
all you can fucking draw about me that's that you're old no look up at the logo I guess
oh what the fuck am I doing what is this shit should whip out my drawing tablet for
me it's better with a mouse better with a mouse no it's better with the mouse if it looks like
and it looks like it looks great would you oh I'm done what's text say can't tell you
this is these are items okay that's all I'm saying 100% wood wood why not we need to put
the chat looks in quick oh good answer oh yeah you guys aren't ready for mine oh god we need
some detail was the Americans always have like a freckle
how's your tongue to describe what is okay what the fuck
oh shit um
there we go
there you go what do you think
oh my god I don't know what he looks like
oh god hold on wait she's so far away
oh right I don't know what I had to look it up I'm just guessing I'm just going for it
oh wait I don't look like that
don't don't question this
don't question this
what's that
how do you draw I hate you
oh I don't know how to draw this is so terrible that's that's pretty good right
the guys agree they agree with me oh my god this is something
I don't know what
this is awful I'm sorry
this is this is I don't know let's
let's draw some hair yeah oh my god
yeah
oh my goodness oh my god I can't
that's very nice thank you I'm glad you agree each other
the leaflings are saying I'm a true artist wait wait no
Emmie's hair is not orange is it she's Emmie's ginger oh my god
yo you saw you had blonde your hair is orange I thought you were blonde
no what the fuck are you looking at
is this the right OG sign I'm sorry I had my image
what does that even say
which one of you speaks Spanish because I
what
oh my god
what do I look like
oh wait I can't even draw the fucking toilet
what do I even look like
this is terrible
I love this shit it's so fucking cursed
hits his armpits we're like we're grabbing on to the ground for dear life in this way
right armpits so I don't know oh my god
because because none of you guys know like some English phrases and or some like jokie phrases
so I can already like I'm what I'm hearing is that a lot of you guys are misinterpreting
what I've written and it's very funny it's going all over his back it's not looking
okay
how do you draw an angry mouth like uh oh there we go
and then
okay
if you're a painter it's our pates we need to draw
we need to sweat this is amazing what does the Walmart logo look like with
oh it's your your armpits has become sentience
I'm not even gonna explain to mercy
oh wait don't you
oh wait
I don't know I don't know if this makes it better it makes it worse it makes it worse
it makes it worse oh my
this is too fucking funny
perfect
okay okay so okay let's see I see so I said I see with Nigel Thornberry's face
saying smashing
that's so fucking good
oh
What is this?
It's a cactus!
Oh my god!
Why does she look like she looks like she's...
Okay, Amy. Go ahead.
Oh no.
It grows thicker with all the love he has for me.
It grew six times that day.
Oh.
This is scrawny.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Madeleine cheesey, fester and fat.
Oh no!
I feel like our feet is actual cheese.
I know.
Hey!
I like that fove!
And every stinky peat...
Which is real...
Is feets, but like...
but like, we'll slay.
And then she drew pits.
Oh my God, that's too good.
Is she cutting out?
Yeah, she's cutting out for me too.
She's screaming so loud.
Oh no, not this one.
Wait, okay.
Not this one.
The spot is over.
You okay?
I got it from A.
Very good artist.
I got it from fucking A.
Thank you.
What does that even mean?
When your job is a poo,
so when your poo hits your prostate on the way out,
it feels like a poo.
Jarby was a poo.
Jarby is a poo.
What is this?
Is Amy sucking?
Amy's suckers are never hot too.
Oh wait, is she giving a blowjob?
That's what it looks like.
That's what it looks like to me.
Oh, oh.
Real?
Oh my God.
I love this.
This is so fucking good.
The drill is so good.
Oh boy.
We are.
It's an old boy.
Over some pie.
Okay, that's cute.
That's cute.
I love that.
That's really cute toy.
How is that a cat?
Meow.
Meow, winky face.
Okay, it's a winky face.
I was like, what is meow?
I was like, who?
It's Spanish, haven't I?
It's Spanish.
We are so good.
That's good.
I love that.
Oh.
Oh no.
Okay, this makes sense.
This makes sense of what Earth we were drawing.
Because we have to check out and like that's items on the shelves.
I worked really hard.
Oh my God.
Oh, this is a good time for it.
I see you understood me.
Oh my God.
Oh, I love the details.
Taking a magic shot.
Oh no, did it go to DC?
Is there a check?
Yeah.
Is there a DC check?
Are you in the lobby?
Do you need to reload the lobby?
It's going to do it on its own usually.
No, I'm gone.
The link should be in the discord.
Don't show your fucking screen on the discord.
Yeah.
Don't do that.
I don't see all of our naughty photos we just send to each other.
I want to do that.
It's mostly memes.
Any memes.
I mean, to be fair, we did share.
We did share some actually.
We did share some lucky nudes of ours.
They've seen my titties.
I saw Brooklyn as the girls with my nudes.
So I was like, this is what Amy would do.
This is what A.C. would do.
Your discord is so chaotic.
Okay, real though.
But also, I did snort out my tea.
It went down the wrong hole and went up my nose.
Wow, Marcy, I hear you snort in tea.
This is what got me off at the stock throne.
Is this better?
It hurts so much.
Can you hear me now?
Oh, yeah.
Oh my god.
That's why you guys win riffs on to me.
I'm so sorry.
My clit is getting a little heart beat right now every time you talk.
Oh no.
I was muted and my thingy was turned down.
That's my bad.
Oopsie.
I feel like Azura could do a really good Jennifer Coolidge impression.
Jennifer Coolidge.
I don't know what Jennifer Coolidge is impression.
She was like, wait, you don't know Jennifer Coolidge?
Jennifer Coolidge.
I am such a big tittie.
Oh my god.
I can't do it.
Jennifer Coolidge.
Speaking of your gap for the Rizzler.
That's so good.
Why are we opening our gap for the Rizzler?
I just dropped the bass.
Blown, blown.
The discreet is not working.
Click that link in the general description.
It's not with discreet's preference.
Is it only in that end?
No.
Are you okay?
What is happening?
All I hear is screaming.
Your mic cuts out.
So it just goes eww.
Eww.
I don't even know what's happening.
It's constantly loading.
It says, did you know
Group DLs
can have up to 10 members?
I'm sorry.
Now I see the discord.
If I open it up, you guys can't see it.
My discord is just broken.
I don't see anything else.
I would close the window capture
in the OBS just in case.
Yes, you can turn it off.
Are we starting a new lobby?
A new lobby?
Hang on.
Let me invite to this lobby.
That's power.
Are we going to a different room?
I don't know.
What is that?
I only see one of you.
On mine, sorry.
A new one?
There's another one.
Are you okay?
Okay, which one should we play?
Which one?
Normal, which we just did.
Knock off, keep yourself focused.
Try to replicate the drawings while the clock gets faster.
Animation.
Create animations in a collaborative way.
Icebreaker, play with a sentence.
Drawings, exquisite corpse.
Create surrealist characters connected by the top of the drawings.
Don't know what that means.
Hold on.
Burp friends, have a good time with that.
Compliment, complete the sketch.
Start with basic lines and see other players' interpretations.
Masterpiece,
create a piece of art, play in a single turn with no time limit.
I feel like story would be funny.
Write a narrative using only the previous sentence as a reference.
Yes, okay, okay.
Story, story, story.
Do you want to do a story?
Let's try story.
What are we doing?
What is this?
Start writing a story.
Wait, do I have to write a full story or just a sentence?
Just a sentence.
Just one sentence.
Okay, okay.
Do you like write the whole story or no?
No, you have really limited characters.
I don't know it.
No!
What did you do?
There's time, there's time.
15 seconds, love.
Oh my god, I wanted to write more.
I wanted to write more.
You can only write one sentence.
Fuck.
Shit.
The end.
We are not being attack allegations.
We are not.
What the fuck is happening?
Oh, they're going to know this is me spelling it
because I didn't use a Z on that.
I'm just going to leave it like that.
Yep, I'm sending it.
I'm not even spell checking.
Fuck it.
I'm bad at stories.
What?
So big.
Oh, the sentence is so small.
I want to give up everything.
Me too.
Let's do short.
I think I get shorter over time.
I want to be like, bi-bing.
I'm going to write until, fuck.
What?
Um, okay.
Let's see.
Oh, no.
Fuck.
Fuck, I'm so bad.
It's funny because
I hate this. I can't think of anything.
The wavelengths, the snowberries, the snippets,
the pin pals,
the bleeding hearts and the harem
all get to see this unfold
and we're all just taping like
Oh, fuck it.
I don't fucking know.
Oh, you.
Wait, is that the fucking
and
happy kitty
sleepy kitty
purr purr purr.
You watch fucking
big bang theory.
Wait, that's my spell.
Paris.
Fuck.
Give me more.
I need more letters.
I need more like
amazing
writer.
They jerk so hard.
Motherfuckers want to find me.
That sounds like sheavey.
No.
They jerk so hard.
Motherfuckers want to find me.
I don't know this lyric though.
This agency
is crazy.
We can't just
I spelled it wrong but that's the point.
I hate that's like
they don't give you enough to write.
It's like
this is not enough.
Fuck off.
Oh boy. Okay, let's see what's happening.
What the fuck is going to be?
Let's do the auto.
This is terrible.
How about everybody reads their own story?
Yeah, of course.
Okay, I go first.
In a galaxy far far away
there was a goat with big titties.
She had so much milkers
and started raining milk.
Azera then went home
to make an empire made milk daily.
It was so successful
the neighboring kingdoms became jealous.
They also wanted some of the juicy.
Ew cooties are not good.
Good.
You're not good.
Oh boy.
Why do we both start to sing?
There was a boy by a princess
who was trying to fit in too.
Oh
My hand yeah
I didn't know what this is but
I was like this thing didn't change.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
I was so hard.
Ronnie, who was in Paris?
I was in Paris!
It was just a beach of agency that was lit.
They all couldn't control the urges that they had.
So they danced, the pee-pee danced until they...
Then finally, they peed everywhere on the floor, the walls, the bed, the kind.
We're all filled up.
There's everywhere, but he loved it.
The fact that we got the best prompt before AC came out with that.
He's either going to be AC or not.
AC got a box of booze!
AC in the morn.
Heard.
Sevens character added.
This is so good.
Okay.
Once upon a time, there were whores.
They were the eliters of whores.
Bitches in the wild west.
They all were really cute cowgirls.
Boozy cats.
So cute.
So fuzzy.
So pussy-warm.
Big bang theory.
More like bang-bang your mom last night.
You keep my mom out of your home now.
Sorry.
10 out of 10.
At the time, they were like big thoms.
Oh, no.
What's going on?
Big thoms!
No, no, no.
It took a lot!
What's going on?
My face hurts a lot.
This is so bad.
Once upon a time,
she even had to take a nap.
A community zero wrote about each other.
She was sad because she realized
she didn't have a prostate.
I said shit.
No way!
Why do I keep talking about shit all the time?
Alright, this is so bad. I hate this.
Fuck no!
No, I didn't want to be pregnant by Sonic!
Ezra, do you have a make filter on? I can never hear you.
I don't.
Piss me, you don't!
Turn that mic.
Get us!
I don't have a filter on!
No, it's fine!
You don't have a filter on!
There's no filter on?
No, there's no filter on.
You're still series filter.
I don't have a filter. I don't have one on.
Definitely, so you guys can hear it on all my phones.
What is happening?
Hang on.
Can't wait for the board if they survive.
Yeah, these ones, I don't know.
They'll be fine, don't worry about it.
You guys don't play this one or do you want to try another one?
It's peaking.
That was an incomplete drawing.
Please, please, no more shits.
No more shits!
No promises!
No promises, I can't promise.
Did you guys miss stuff?
Did you miss the compliment?
Yeah, I promised that.
Compliment.
All the actions are a mystery.
Drawings and sentences are hidden during this.
You can't hear Mercy?
Sorry, sorry.
Because I was coughing because I was laughing
my side hurts so badly.
No.
Okay, Mercy test complete.
Do you want to do compliment?
What is that?
We draw on each other's drawings, basically.
Oh, we should try that.
I think that would be fun.
Yeah.
We could draw so much piss.
Oh god.
Let's start sketching some basic lines.
Okay.
Let me do this.
Maybe I could just...
Maybe I'll do some basic lines.
Like, ooh.
Okay, boom.
Ooh.
Wait, now I'm just going to draw a bunch of dicks.
The castle.
I can't believe it.
No!
Cute.
Blockers.
Oh god.
You know exactly what you did.
And no, I don't have the strength to resist.
What?
Wait, I got it. I got it.
I can make this. I can salvage this.
This is the back legs of it.
And then this is its huge
milkers.
Like...
Oh.
A big
fish up bruh.
Oh my god, I've just made shimmy up.
What the hell?
What is my name?
Oh wait, that's a thing.
Oh no, that looks like...
Dang it.
Give me the pencil.
There we go.
I saved it.
Baby, give you a lot more time
for the second one.
Yeah, you're to finish it.
Ah, you need to finish it.
Okay, I'm fucking stupid, never mind.
Okay.
So am I, don't worry. Saved it.
Let me look at it.
Help.
Let's put some nice shading in.
To make this look extra beautiful.
Wow.
Let's put lipstick on.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
So beautiful.
I saved it.
They prank him.
I think this is the best one.
Maybe a better one.
Oh, wait.
Who drew a pair of hairy ballsack?
Come on.
What the fuck?
You have to add the shaft.
I really know what I want to do,
but I know I shouldn't do it
because we're on YouTube.
I'm missing this.
Oh, no.
I can't make one thing.
This is amazing.
Oh, wait, maybe. Hold on.
I got it.
I gotta go back.
This is so fucking good.
Let's fucking go.
I'm trying so hard right now.
I can't even think of anything to say.
I'm like trying so hard.
Oh, my gosh. Use your imagination.
Use your imagination.
There you go.
I'm so proud of you.
Aww.
Refling.
We need to be nice to the camera.
Your laugh is so fucking lazy.
Thank you.
I got you a six.
I think they did my really well.
Yeah, it's a water bottle.
That's the best I got.
Quick quick quick.
I saved the pair of mall sacs.
Did you make it into a dog or something?
No, it just works.
Can you, Senpais, can you do better, shut the fuck up.
I love when you do that.
Shut the fuck up.
Oh my God.
What is this?
I got the hairy mall facts.
What?
Hold on. Give me a second.
You're asking me not to draw a vagina.
What do I do here?
How am I supposed to do this?
What can we do here?
How do I make this?
How do I save this?
Hmm.
Uh...
Okay.
Okay, I won't draw that.
Because that would be...
Oh my god. I just realized...
I'll draw this in the sky.
Mercy snippets of like fucking Grogu.
Hmm.
From Star Wars.
Oh wait, no. Is it heartbreak on the chair?
I did it! Saved it!
I saved it!
Women were less immature than men.
You're wrong.
I was gonna draw a coochie or a woman giving birth,
but I'm not gonna...
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
I literally don't know what the fuck I'm doing right now.
There you go.
Wait, hold on.
Oh my god, I have time.
One, two, three.
I guess who it is now.
I can do this.
What the fuck I'm doing?
Fuck!
And then pen pals.
Pen pals.
Fuck.
I'm running out of time.
Oh my god, this is...
And then volcano.
These are light ones.
I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Fuck!
Are you out of...
I don't know, I don't know.
These are light ones!
I did it.
Oh god, refunds.
Refunds, how could I forget your...
I saved it, I saved it!
I think I did a good job.
This is the best I got.
I ain't got nothing.
No!
I don't like this.
Why do I feel like...
This is a really specific reference.
I don't know if anyone's gonna get it,
but there used to be a flash game
where your guy was on like a snowboard.
I love that game!
Yeah, someone should literally just drawn that.
Literally, this is perfect.
That's my drawing.
Someone says lane raider.
Oh, is that what it's called?
Rift.
What is bear pantsu?
Oh!
Panties.
I don't want to weigh all of this.
People were asking me to draw a bear wearing underwear.
I was like, what the fuck is wrong with you guys?
Panties and pants.
I remember fancy pants.
Because he had big old pants that were fancy.
Rain up and now it's not the time.
And you know the story!
Is he blundered or did I make that up?
You know the story!
I might make that up.
Wait, hydration check, girl.
Is that a one-year-old dying?
Okay.
You know the story.
His pants read.
He's gargling my balls, sorry.
He had no hair color, but his pants read yellow.
Did he have a beard? I don't know.
I'm going to do something.
Needs hip dial.
Yeah, you're right.
I don't really know how to do that though.
Can I zoom in?
Yeah!
Something with a beer braid.
Braid is pantsu?
Wait, it doesn't have pants?
Yeah!
No fuck, I didn't mean to have that.
What is this? Who drew ball sacks everywhere?
It's not you, Shibi.
I only see boobs.
No, I didn't draw a ball sack.
I got it.
Who's whispering?
What? I have no idea.
What? Who's whispering?
Who's whispering?
Who's whispering some evil incantations to us?
Wait, no, that's not nice.
This is all a C right now,
and I'm not even going to pretend otherwise.
It was definitely Azura that drew the ball sack, 100%.
Why do I feel like this is a lie?
No, I didn't draw it.
I'm really drawing over it right now.
If you guys didn't know,
Azura's ears actually have golden
little jewelry on the end of them.
Oh no.
This is icing.
She pimped out with jewelry, but it's like
not a vanity thing.
Here you go. Gifts.
Going for her first bike ride.
Right.
Isn't cheating to erase? Aw, fuck it is.
Isn't it cute?
Right.
So if you didn't know, when a woman
when a woman lactates,
she will have a...
I got it.
It goes through the fabric, okay?
So they'll be like a couple.
I know this isn't Azura's.
Aw, it's terrible.
Get rid of that.
Oh my god.
I want to live with my life.
I was trying to talk about lactation, though.
Yeah, it was right before she said chocolate.
Milk.
The best I got.
Shit.
That's the timer.
Oh.
I thought you were drawing a cute bunny face.
Nah, they have some titties, mate.
It's all I can see.
I have saved...
I have single-handedly saved the stream, probably.
Let me do that.
This is supposed to be it.
The liquid.
Oh, I have to draw my own drawing?
Fine.
What is this?
That's nothing!
Fine.
I don't even know what to draw for my own drawing.
I started it,
and I'm going to finish it.
It's me.
Okay, fucking man over here.
I don't know.
I'm already pooped from this.
Just make a little snack.
Just a little snack.
A little whip.
It's the old...
It's the old Mac, okay?
Okay.
I would talk, but it takes too much brain power
to do this.
You're a little cheery.
And talk.
Get a little...
Yeah.
Stop!
This is a net.
Yeah.
Pretty good net.
I think I need to grab one.
How do you spell squelch?
Squelch?
Yeah.
Is it the arm that's going?
Oh my god.
Is it the reverse Amazon position
when the girls...
What are you drawing?
Reverse Amazon is like eBay?
Yeah.
That's definitely what it's about.
Wait, any quicker?
Is it hydrate?
No!
Okay, let's see our albums.
Is anybody need to take a quick break
before...
I'm ready.
Let's go.
Let's do this.
That was yours.
Okay, okay.
What the hell?
What?
Oh, he's...
Okay.
Is it Orsor's hand?
Oh my god, I think it's the other...
Yeah, the other me.
Oh, that's so good.
What do you mean you're a bad artist?
That's a very good little bear.
That's beautiful.
That's good.
He got a border under the blanket and everything.
Oh, it's the artist.
Beautiful.
What else could I draw for this?
Oh, that's so cute.
That's so cute.
We're so, so cute.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, die.
Die.
I like it.
I did it for his milk.
Open now.
Oh my god.
I saved them.
I lied.
I didn't save the stream at all.
I was...
If I don't see a snail...
Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's so cute.
Oh, it's mine.
It is.
I love replays.
Oh my god, that's so cute.
Oh.
And then there's me.
And then there's...
I was like, it makes me...
Oh my god.
Mine broke.
Oh, that's so cute.
Oh.
How is he cute?
Yeah, that was cute.
He's a rat boy.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's so cute.
That's so cute.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That's so cute.
Oh.
Literally me.
That's me.
Oh.
That's mine.
Oh my god.
He's so bad.
I can't show that.
I see.
We'll do it me and the boys.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh my god, that's so good.
Why the mono bro?
Wait.
Why are you guys...
Oh my god.
Really calm.
Wait, I drew this little game.
I was like, oh, this is a lane ranger.
I like it.
Oh, that's good.
That's creative.
Yeah, that's good.
Oh, I love that.
Oh.
That's really cute.
I love that.
Oh, that's cute.
I told you.
I love you.
What is this?
Lama Chuba for Gentoo.
I was gonna say that's a good one
and then I saw the thing on the right.
That's cute, Mercy.
I told you.
She's learning how to ride a bike.
What the fuck?
Oh, that was good.
Oh, that was so fucking good.
I ended up being the most innocent.
Oh, that was good.
Oh my god.
Time and stuff.
Help.
I can't breathe.
This is what it's like to be in VLR.
So fucking giving birth!
I want to figure out what icebreaker is.
Icebreaker is kind of boring.
What are we doing?
I'll stop it.
What?
Icebreaker is kind of boring.
Yeah, it's boring.
Can I cancel it?
If you want.
How do I cancel it?
Wait, are we doing this or are we cancelling it?
I don't know.
I cancel it.
What is happening?
Oh, there's a fucking ad.
I'm just making another room.
I'm making another room.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right.
Where is my carrier that?
You guys can see John Snow and Sansa start.
Wait, no, you put me back in.
They still advertise.
Wait, so do we have a new one?
Do we have a new one?
Yeah, it says one of seven.
Wait, what is happening?
I don't know what is happening.
Somebody else make a lobby.
It's not the greatest, but we can just play it.
No, somebody else make a lobby.
Do we have a new lobby or not?
Somebody else make it because
I made a new one.
I was trying to make a new one.
Everyone, hate the asset.
Hate the game.
The graphic phone window.
And then someone make a new one.
I can't make it because of my connections.
I'll do it.
Okay.
See, Emmy proven what a big girl she is.
That was so fucking weird.
I'm sorry.
So fucking creepy.
I'm so sorry.
Sorry.
It's so chaotic.
I don't know why there's two of me on the screen.
I hate that.
So we are opening in your lobby?
Let me just put up a new one.
She was a link in the discord, you can hate.
Okay, okay, okay.
I understand.
Okay.
Understood.
So, yes sir.
Let me open the link.
There we go, nice and easy.
I'll go Apecha.
Okay, is everyone here?
I'm here.
Yeah, we're here.
Okay, which one do you want to play?
I don't know.
Knock off is fun.
Because it's like, super...
Try to replicate the drawing.
Oh yeah, do knock off.
Do knock off, that looks good.
Okay.
Because you make it pretty drawing and then
it becomes hell.
Wait, why are we supposed to draw?
Anything you want.
Anything?
No, not you.
Maybe not anything for you.
No, not shit.
Please give us something.
I'm being put on the spot, my main's going blank.
Okay, hold on.
Let's do a count.
Cheebie, we can't see.
I'll draw.
I'm taking off the blindfold or fine now.
I'll draw Cheebie.
Should we all just draw somebody?
Oh.
No, I'm joking.
I was like, ooh, I'm kind of locked in now.
Sorry, sorry.
I've decided to draw one of us
that I have already said out loud.
I don't know what to draw.
Guys, give me an idea.
Don't put me on the spot.
Don't put me on the spot, I don't know.
I don't even know what to draw.
Put me on the G-spot.
Oh, one of you guys, so I'm going to choose.
Yeah.
Are you coming for a ride?
This is terrible on a mouse.
That one's actually funny.
How much time do we have?
Can I draw the whole gang again?
I'll make it.
You have quite a bit of time with this one.
Okay, hold on.
What the fuck is the whole gang with this?
Oh, that's not very...
No, no, no, no.
How the fuck do you draw something sitting down?
Oh my God, I'm having a stroke.
I'm not a good guy.
What on earth?
There's a good kind?
I'm supposed to be at the very...
That's close enough.
How do you say after this?
Oh my God.
I'm going to draw harmony.
I'm going to draw your name.
Perfect. I can't draw like this.
Wait, it has kind of like...
His nickname.
We need to draw the devilish hat.
Fuck.
This is hard because I don't know what to fucking draw.
Get creative, nerds.
Jeez, it's not that hard.
I'm doing it.
I'm playing dead, okay?
Okay, Miss Artis.
I'm playing dead.
I'm just going to draw myself casual
and it comes out with this fucking banger of a commission.
It would probably cost like $500 to do.
And I'm like, oh my God.
I'm going to make a VTuber model.
Don't ask the way.
I wish I could...
I'm doing a figure-nerval talent.
Speaking of that,
send me a fucking marshmallow.
They were like, thank you for not tying down
your talents to the designs
that you assigned them and they can be more themselves.
And I'm like, yeah, well,
why would I do that?
I was like, I don't know why.
I feel like it's such a basic thing.
What the fuck do I need to draw next?
A bleeding heart.
Yeah, we're more like building upon
characters rather than
changing everything.
Oh, someone rated the VTuber.
They were like, the only thing that would have
been better is if you let them design
their models.
From the start, I'm like, bro, it took me
a fucking year to get here.
Oh my God, give me...
It takes forever to...
It is not like an overnight thing.
Draw and rig a VTuber model.
You can ask Amy.
She knows how to do it.
It's a lot of work.
Oh my God.
Yeah, there's only a select few corpos
that will let you do that.
It literally takes a little long.
Oh shit. Oh shit.
Man, this is rough.
Usually ones that have like artists in house
are like...
Yeah, we don't.
This is so bad.
Most companies, if not all of them,
say first, you
will have
pre-made
pre-made.
So it's not actually standard
for people to choose.
Yeah, it's really not.
That's why it's usually they
cast for the roles.
You have to fit the character they're looking for
and have the voice.
Oh.
There.
What the fuck is that?
Stop.
Oh, it looks like an abomination.
Oh.
Oh no.
I'm complicated.
What is this?
Fuck.
Okay.
I like how cute this is.
Okay, now we have to draw it.
Are we ready?
Yeah.
No, but...
I have to be...
I have to be ready for it.
Even if I'm not...
It's okay.
Just draw it your way
and that's the fun part.
Yeah. Very nice.
I've already forgot which position everyone...
Fuck.
Bro, this is so bad.
Sorry, we flinched honestly.
I would talk more, but this takes so much brain power
to do this.
I'm so brain dead.
I feel so bad.
I'm like dying.
I'm reading chat, I'm reading everything,
but I'm not responding.
I'm so sorry.
I can see everyone and see what you're all saying.
I'm just really in this.
I feel like I'm just...
Fuck, I'm just fucking losing it.
Oh my god, wait!
I forgot there was a shorter time!
Fuck!
That's far too short, so it's...
This is why it's chaotic.
Why was the other one longer?
I don't remember what...
Ah!
Oh my god, what?
What is this?
Okay.
I have no clue what it was.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Fuck, the time!
We draw this as fast as we can.
Oh fuck!
Ah!
No, no, no, no!
Not like this!
Shit, shit, shit!
I can't remember what it looked like.
Is there supposed to be someone in a pirate boat, by the way?
Because I don't think I saw it.
Is there supposed to be a person in it?
I don't know, it's already gone.
It's just a person.
It's supposed to...
It's supposed to go really fast, so it...
Oh my god!
Okay, that's easy enough.
That's easy enough.
Oh, it's already up!
Okay.
Gotta go fast, gotta go fast!
Gotta go fast!
Faster, faster, oh fuck.
Faster, faster!
Ah!
Oh my god, I am so sorry.
Come on.
Faster, oh!
Faster!
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, hey, it's me.
Why is it so flat?
Oh no, no, no!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, we can do this, we can do this.
We can do this.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Don't panic, don't panic.
The great part is that we are all panicking.
Oh no, no, no, no!
One more time.
What is this?
What even is that?
Okay, this is easy, this is easy, easy, easy.
This has to be mittens, this has to be mittens.
Easy, easy, easy.
Was it blue? I can't remember blue.
Let's fucking go.
Man, this looks like shade, but oh wow.
I mean, that's close enough.
Oh my god.
That's close enough.
That's amazing.
I love this.
What does her have all the time?
I did not have any time for this.
I was like, this is Mr. Min.
This is Mr. Min.
At least it's me and the cat.
Oh my god.
I'm excited to cat.
That's a little campfire with all of us together.
That's fucking cute.
I don't have time.
That's what it's supposed to be.
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck in the face.
That's so good.
At the end of the day,
we're all just suffering here.
This is good.
This stayed good.
That's perfect circle.
I was getting more and more depressed, somebody said.
Oh, she's not in jail.
She's at the cage.
I thought she was in jail.
OK, that's fine.
I get it.
Oh, my god.
She was under arrest.
I love this.
Help.
It's back down.
She broke her jail by the end.
Oh, my goodness.
She's free.
Wow.
I love all the details.
One piece.
I was like, why the heck are we doing this?
I was like, what the heck are we doing here?
I was like, stop me.
Oh, no.
I was just getting ugly.
I was trying to draw the line.
Oh, my god.
I was trying to draw the line on it.
I was like, I can't.
I was like, oh.
She was shooting her piss.
Wait, that's supposed to be me?
Are you kissing as a girl?
You're giving the rest of the piss it needs to serve her?
The piss will revive him.
Oh.
Oh, my god.
Oh, it's still good, right?
One more.
Which one?
Give us one more.
One more.
What would have we not done?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Secret.
All the actions are a mystery.
Drawing incentives are hitting during the game.
What's secret?
Secret seems rough.
I've never done that one before.
All right, since they're a mystery.
OK.
We'll try it.
Last friend, boys.
Last friend.
OK, OK, OK.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what?
I can't see what I'm writing.
Oh, secret.
How am I supposed to know what I'm writing?
Wait, what?
Huh?
Yeah.
Oh, no, wait.
You run out of freaking words?
Oh, bro.
I can't erase my things.
I don't know.
What is this?
Of course.
What is happening?
It just appears.
Oh, we can't see what we're drawing.
What?
OK, we'll draw fast.
We'll draw fast.
What the fuck?
OK.
I don't know.
I think I'm going to just guess what it is, where it is.
That's so funny.
Oh, god.
What the fuck?
Oh, no, no.
I'm going to try to draw.
Why is it so hard to draw with a bow?
What is that?
OK.
I failed that.
Oh, no.
I didn't finish it.
Oh, come on.
What the fuck?
What?
What does that even mean?
What the fuck?
I think it's so sad.
OK.
Oh, fuck.
I don't know what else to draw.
That's exactly what I drew, I think.
Is this a vain reference?
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
Locked in.
I locked in.
Did I give...
Wait, I spelled that wrong.
Wait, did I give them bodies?
Oh, my God.
I don't even know where they are.
I don't know.
Taking a shot in the dark.
Where do you know what that is going to be interpreted as?
And will I stop the creative flow?
Do you stop?
Oh, my God.
No.
Emmy's got a hoodie here.
Oh, sugar.
I don't...
Fucking...
I put juice on her right now.
I don't fucking know.
I didn't even know what the fuck I'm doing anymore.
I'm fucking dying.
What is this?
What?
What is happening?
What is this?
Someone had a stroke.
Could you ever do this one?
Hope you're feeling OK.
Hope you're doing all right.
Make sure you hydrate.
Fuck, I didn't have enough time to write it.
Oh, man.
How do I even draw this?
This is...
That's the tongue.
This is literally everywhere.
Wait.
Okay, this is so difficult.
Fuck am I drawing?
I need like motion swipes as well.
And a little arrow to indicate.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know.
Yeah, there we go.
I think I drew it correctly.
A little bit of lips.
Cute?
I don't know.
I just drew anything.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I just drew everything.
What did you say?
I can't wait to see the end of this.
Yeah, you're all in trouble.
This is going to be something else.
This is going to be fucking interesting.
What's going on in the ceiling?
Oh, I need to draw on the ceiling quick.
Oh, I think I just drew it.
Oh, God.
Oh, boy.
I'm so scared of what these look like.
Same.
Are you serious?
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
I think she's beautiful.
I was like, oh, you're not okay.
I completely missed the book.
She's fucking going.
What are you doing?
I was going to write.
I was going to write even being cooked.
It looked like she was on a stick that's rotating.
No.
Oh, that's why you were humming Indiana Jones.
I was like, where did that come from?
I was trying to write cowboy, but I didn't fit it.
Oh, that's so normal.
I'm kidding.
Wait, where's my coin?
Oh, my God.
I used the color black and I used red as well.
And orange.
Oh, my God.
What is my one?
What the fuck?
I can't read.
Oh, my face.
Snowcow.
Hey.
How are you?
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, my God.
I used the fucking eraser.
That's why you're going to fucking see it.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
How did I get back to Boob?
That's not the right way to run.
Oh, my God.
Well, actually, that potato was really bad.
Never mind.
Oh, wholesome.
You'll learn number one.
Wait, I don't know.
Oh, it's not Earth 3D closer.
No.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is amazing.
That's what we got there.
That book.
Oh, they drew us.
Your mom called me.
Oh it's sexy.
That's so good.
OH MY GOD.
That's so sick.
Oh my god.
Oh, my God.
My cheeks hurt from this moment.
Same.
My jaw hurts.
Oh, okay, okay.
Ah!
Oh, by a train!
Oh, my God.
Oh!
Somebody download that one.
Oh, my God.
That's fucking amazing.
Oh!
That's so fucking funny.
I love this.
What a guy's permission.
That train.
That train is bad.
It's not the premium pass.
That is bad.
As you see at the convention,
they got the premium pass.
That train.
Me.
Hahaha!
Tag yourself on the ropes.
Tying me to the tracks.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna
endure the girls to anything more
because like, our faces are ready
to fall off after that.
Is anyone doing a stream?
Me, I am.
Is anyone?
Are you doing a stream?
No.
I need to pee really bad.
Right.
I'm going to jump out of the call.
And I'm going to jump out of the call.
Man, now I'm sick of my new piss off.
I know.
Let's win it.
I am going to jump out of the call
and do a little satsuthe.
And I'll redirect into Yuzuru, OK?
OK.
I'm going to be in Stardil.
I might play.
Do you guys want me?
I might play some Call of the Lamb.
If someone does a pop-up stream, just tell me.
I'll talk to my reef ones for a bit.
Thank you so, so much, all members and dolls,
for this hilarity that ensued after such a miserable start.
This was amazing.
The art that such a miserable start to power water.
Shat myself for laughing so hard.
Oh, no.
We already know Aces panties are soaked.
So let's not laugh.
And Amy, probably?
No.
All right.
Let me sniff.
Let me sniff test.
Don't do the sniff test.
Rather pungent, my dear.
My bridge just cut out.
You have to take a test.
Like she just disintegrated.
Oh, my god.
Right.
I'm going to jump out of chat.
Thank you so much.
OK, OK, OK.
We'll be doing collabs next week with each other.
So look out for that.
And I'll jump out of chat.
Thank you so much.
My darlings, my daughters, my girls.
I'll talk to you very shortly, OK?
I'm off to the refunds.
I love you, my daughters.
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah.
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah.
OK, all these girls.
These are the yellow girl.
Yeah.
They're so cute, right?
You know, you're still in call.
That was really something.
Wait, are you guys still streaming?
Yeah, I am.
I am, yeah.
I don't know what to do.
I feel like I lost my ability to stream.
You got to go off.
OK, let's go off.
Go to Jeff Channing and then raid into Azra.
I think Azra's next, right?
Yeah, I'm going to be.
I'll see you, but.
Me and Azra are going to be streaming.
She's doing Stardew.
I'm doing Call of the Limb.
Wait, wait.
So Shibi and Azra are going to stream right now?
Yeah, I'm going to keep streaming.
I'm probably going to end this one
so that the bot is separated.
Oh, yeah, actually, I'll end it.
We can do one.
OK, hang up and then I'll go to the just chatting
and then I'll send.
I'll check if y'all ready.
OK, let me just go.
Bye bye.
Hey, guys, that was that was fun.
I'm going to we're going to do a early stream
because why not?
Since I'm already streaming, I was going to take a break,
but that was really fast.
I like in between.
I'm so sorry.
I wasn't talking much.
I'm trying to find the group calling you to get rid of that.
I'm so sorry.
I wasn't talking much.
I wasn't talking very much.
I spent the majority of it laughing too hard.
I was laughing too hard the entire time.
OK, I'm going to end this bot.
OK, in this video, I'm never going
to start up the stardo stream.
OK, so I'll see you guys in just a few minutes.
Sorry.
We'll be streaming pretty much all day.
At least you got plenty of talk for the next stream.
Yeah.
OK, bye bye, everyone.
That was fun.
See you in a few, in a few minutes.
Bye.